what's up I got brand new stand-up
material brand new hour and I got brand
new dates we just added Vancouver Austin
Texas West Palm Beach Florida Miami
Florida pre-sale code Chrissy at the
fountain blue
um all happening in March Vancouver is
February Phoenix January 26 to the 28th
Phoenix that's a big one um and then um
see I'm in Charlotte Asheville and South
Carolina this weekend I believe all the
shows are sold out New Year's Eve in
Huntington Long Island first show sold
out second show is all about gone and
then in January Dallas is sold out but
we still got tickets for Houston and New
Orleans so christycomedy.com for Tiki
wikis
um and I love you and uh Sal is back
this week
foreign
[Music]
you know obviously there's been someone
who's been missing
um each week on hey babe and I just keep
saying he's gonna be back next week he's
gonna be back next week but I want to
share and I'll just be come right out
and say it that Sal is dead
Sal vulcano is no longer with us and
we've been hiding it and and you've been
dealing with it and so I want I I want
he will be back next week on the show
but
I I I I want to say that uh no of course
the guest is Mike that's right
so yeah no of course uh Sal is dead but
he's coming back next week
um as I've said every week since October
how do you think he died Sal I think Sal
I think Sal died from washing his hands
I think he was washing his hands so
aggressively that he slid his wrist I
think he opened I think his manager
killed him
serious
[Music]
he always rubbed me the wrong way
like a like a [ __ ] photographer and
Qatar you know who killed him
[Laughter]
this is not how we were supposed to talk
about hey babe
stop doing Christy chaos twice
all right what are we saying yeah I
don't even remember welcome to the show
Mike Cannon and I I'm gonna be honest
with you we are on Edibles gonna just
flat out say it we are unedible but I
feel like that'll represent the general
energy of this show better yeah
sometimes you know you know
um a salad he's coming back I think
maybe one or two more episodes without
Sally babes and then he's coming back
which will be next week but Sal is a
human edible like he is just a instant
cheer you up in the room type of guy
what a what a warm inviting presence and
that's exactly what I'm feeling coursing
through my blood right now yeah that's
why every time I go around sound my eyes
are red
um because she's a human animal
um no so I I do think yeah the vibe of
this uh uh hey babe is just kind of it's
you know what because we Sal and I
started hey babe because we were like
Hey we're two friends that we're always
talking and telling stories and and
genuinely having a good time and
laughing and we we were like we should
you know make this a podcast we should
manage yeah like we should monetize this
and I feel like saying that getting into
that is and it's like this is what
happens on hey babe because it's just
positive and like you know real what
happens
so
what's positive about it is sorry so
it's what's positive about this is that
you what I just realized is you and I
would sit around and just tell stories
and laugh and have a good time so tell
us how your best friend's brother died
in that car accident
ha
hahaha
do you know what I was thinking about
that actually recently yeah because yeah
I've had so many friends die and just
mysterious one of Mike's friends
genuinely dies yeah the people that are
closest to me just get wiped off the
face of the Earth yeah that's why that's
why he went gray at 27. it might have
something to do with it it like it went
lighter because I was always wearing a
dark suit
yeah the funeral
can I so I had this I had this Vision I
it was a memory because I I actually
like cross-checked it with a bunch of
people that were there right but when
that my friend uh brothi died in a car
accident we all like flew home everybody
came home from college we all went to
his house we had maybe the craziest
party I've ever been to yeah like in you
know I remember saying like all all the
friends flew home but you took the Bolt
Bus
my parents wouldn't pay for my flight
yeah I wanted they were like your friend
died dude get over it you still have
like four weeks left in the semester and
I was like yeah cool thanks guys this is
the fourth one but please yeah they're
like yeah you must you're used to it you
got a punch card at this point yeah
Mr Cannon you're a piece of [ __ ] but he
actually to his credit he was the one
that ended up flying me home yeah and so
this was actually the first time I got
laid from Comedy is I didn't even start
comedy yet but I started telling people
I wanted to do it and we were doing
every illicit substance known to man
like you know hard stuff basically all
of us trying to follow our friend right
and I mean Xanax all you know you name
it on top were you guys using freezebong
what's the you'll find out at
patreon.com christycomedy freeze pipe
freeze pie
foreign
[Music]
some girl took me like into her car
outside of the house in February too
which was insane yeah but then this
image came to me the other day where all
of us were outside like the day of his
funeral and we're in the snow and we're
building like an eight-foot dick out of
snow in the back of his house his mom's
house she lives there his whole family's
there grandparents like who dies right
the kid who's dead okay and we we just
hey babe we built this thing that was
like Shaq's height right and then I
remember looking over and one of our
friends who hadn't been home yet was
like walking in and hysterically crying
so it was like this crazy contrast of me
shaping a snow [ __ ] and interviewing my
friend's funeral genuinely so happy then
being brought back to Earth of why we
were there in the first day yeah you
just forget I just forgot and it just
hit me recently like I said a mound of
snow or a dish
I read this book have you ever read
Victor Frankel's
um what's his famous book that he wrote
while he was in Auschwitz Victor Frank
I'm blanking on the name oh man search
for meaning Victor funkel man search for
meaning you know he he was a holocaust
Survivor and he wrote he was writing
these he wrote a book about the
Holocaust like after surviving but like
he was a girl like a lot of people
survived the Holocaust were young yeah
they were children he was like a man in
his 20s or 30s and he wrote this book I
think he was writing notes in the
Holocaust that he managed to to keep wow
you know like managed to like hold
secure and he says in that book which
was interesting that he found himself
time and time again waking up and
forgetting that he was in forgetting
that he was in a a concentration camp
yeah because your mind just makes you
want to always go to the Happy this
place yeah it's the preservation yeah so
so it was like wild when I thought of
when I when you said that it made me
think of Auschwitz
isn't that a weird thing though like
just that kind of what the Holocaust oh
yeah I don't know yeah
if you can believe in Santa
um oh that's actually what I want to ask
you guys yes you both have kids what's
like dealing with sandals by the way
what's more hey babe than talking about
Santa yeah I mean literally it we're
talking about Sandia because this is hey
babe we both got kids and I'm the only
one on hey babe with kids
um typically typically yeah well no well
no you have kids what are we talking
about yes I do no I'm saying I'm on the
I'm I'm only me has kids you know when
it's me and Sal but you and I have
children yeah yeah dude you're edible
because you know what it is I realize
this this the highest I felt for and
been enjoying it for the longest amount
of time because usually by now I'm
getting tingly or whatever so maybe the
maybe for me to feel better I have to
take more I might be taking too little
and it's not giving me what I need do
you know what to do level up do you know
what doing more does for me personally
is it uh it reinforces the trust fall
it's like when I take five milligrams I
tend to even like fight it a little bit
and pretend to be more sober than I am
because it's easier right but when you
take a hundred there's no pretending you
are in you're in the [ __ ] you know what
I mean so you may as well just trust
fall back and allow whatever happened to
happen because that's uh that's just the
situation you found yourself can I take
some of the Edibles uh that you have
home yeah yeah you can I'll give you
money um what do you uh what does it
cost nothing can I legally get it's
legal by the way so this isn't even like
you don't have to yeah you don't have to
do this
yes I don't know if you can sell it on
air here no I'm giving it I'm donating
to the show but you get Mike arrested
yeah but the but the um
the uh uh the Edibles you're about to
give me the Edibles that you gave me
yeah yeah without my consent
[Laughter]
yes yes so
um is is uh can I buy those in New York
you can buy those across the street from
the comedy seller because that's where I
got them and then so the one that you
gave me that I'm feeling nice from yeah
yeah so do they sell 1 000 milligram
bags and again this is perfectly legal
but how is this legal in New York I
thought you had to go to other states to
do this no because it's recreationally
legal in New York City and in New York
state but they have just fumbled the bag
in terms of setting up any kind of
economic infrastructure because there
are no real dispensaries there's no like
true thorough laws written about it yet
it's kind of the Wild West there's Vans
parked on the corner with like a weed
leaf on them that you can donate thirty
dollars to and get an eighth there's
every Bodega south of Harlem gets free
ride to sell whatever the [ __ ] they want
you go up into Harlem and they're
getting raided all the time and Rob dude
it's like it's like there's like some
crazy weird you know weed racial
Injustice happening in
[Laughter]
a bad batch of weed from those guys
because I'm always afraid of yeah that's
what I worry about like is there
fentanyl in in it like could there be my
question here was the package the stuff
that you gave me this package is it so
it they sell in New York but it's not
some guy making it it's no no no now
it's FDA approved it's not FDA approved
but it's definitely made it's a lab it's
made in a lab and it's made by people
that know what they're doing but they
could slip a little Fanny in it they
could do whatever they want listen man
they could put fentanyl in a burger like
it doesn't mean that they're doing it I
feel like sometimes it is right you just
take one and you start to not out no I
but I don't buy my flour typically from
there like the the actual weed I don't
buy it from there I just get edibles I
get uh I get flour from a grower now
what's the most Edibles you've ever done
in like a day
um I mean I've done where it gets like
real like reality is truly slippery yeah
and things start like collapsing
underneath you we'll have 500 milligrams
did you
do 150 for that and people you know
everybody has their different doses some
people spin off the planet on ten or
five or whatever you saw those kids who
overdosed on Edibles is that true what
happens
it was pretty crazy I don't know I want
to see the details it sounds like
they're like Greening out and throwing
up it sounded like uh manslaughter it
sounds like someone set them up oh the
Idaho kids was that what that was yeah
Edibles yeah Idaho story that Idaho
story first of all here's what's sad
about the Idaho story is they haven't
even I guarantee you one thing to be
true I get if I say one true thing this
week it's this
and everything that I've said to you
Jasmine
oh that's sweet yeah
yeah that's true you look nervous
it's all good stuff yeah
so one thing this is
this is as true as true can be this is
as true as true TV
which is where my best friend Sal's show
is on and I love that Network yeah and
that show so so
this is literally anybody gonna enjoy
watching this episode I'm loving it
Chris is melting down give me more
animals what do you feel dude what do
you feel right now so what I dude I feel
I feel honestly it's one of these
even though I'm sitting cross-legged I
feel like I got two feet on the ground
yeah I feel stable and sturdy and
rounded yeah and grounded and and um and
I also feel like um you know I was
planning to go home to my family to not
miss an event in my daughter's life but
I'm too high to drive so I guess gotta
watch the World Cup with Mike
you gotta stay in the city for safety
yeah that's what it is yeah I know it
was a recital for your father but
the annual father's recital
not even Father's Day just father's
recital
oh my God oh my God
there was fentanyl in that
so so you have kids
yeah I'm gonna get to my kids but let me
talk about the Idaho murders that's
right
[Laughter]
true and [ __ ] up about the Idaho
murders okay is I guarantee you
that they have not found the killer yet
the Killer is still on the loose the
families are haven't even buried some of
their loved ones but I bet you any
amount of money there have been already
not one but multiple TV scripts
submitted to Hollywood producers about
the Idaho murders they're trying to
capitalize and monetize on their
families immediately I guarantee you
that's what's happening yeah and and and
it and especially now that's but it's
not happening on my TV show that I'll be
announcing soon there were no scripts
that there's we didn't even talk about
the items we do not uh we do not profit
off of the blood of children yeah but
honestly Mike what were you saying
oh we were talking Santa yeah that's
right talk about Santa who who's you
know camping
camping suspect that probably didn't do
it
dude you know that Idaho
oh my God that's a movie serial killer
Santa yes yeah dude yeah [ __ ] yeah is
that not a thing already what's that new
one with the guy from uh stranger things
right it's like him beaten
a violent night like Silent Night
[Laughter]
so I know Mike's doing Santa this
weekend yeah with kids I've already done
it too though oh you did it yeah yeah
how many times you have to do it I don't
know we just do it we just keep going
what is it you go to bring Santa to sit
on Santa's lap yeah I'm just keep
putting your young boys
no because he'll do it with like he did
it by himself he did it with uh my niece
and he did it with his friend uh Layla
like he'll go with other friends and
we'll go with other you know parents
that I can stomach yeah well you have a
tough do you guys hang out with other
parents no well we have yeah we have a
couple of parents
um uh we hang out with they're all
pretty cool but I would they're really
one guy's really cool I I feel like
though I still hang out mostly though
with just my friends from home like and
not my my daughter's friends from school
like she can have a play date whatever
always nice but I don't there's there's
been no like long-term friendships I
don't think formed from when does that
happen or does or besides one guy yeah
who's probably watching
I know
I'm sure you and him meeting at the foot
of your driveway dressed like Tony
Soprano with an open robe that sandals
out it's been like so what's up
[Laughter]
dude yeah [ __ ] it yeah so so so yeah but
um
what uh did you do Santa yeah no we
didn't do Santa yet we just got our
Christmas tree nice yeah we brought our
Chris what'd you get banged out for not
actually not bad a guy on Staten Island
um he's right his at it's right off um
this tree fell off the back of a truck
yeah listen you heard me talk about it
this episode Babel speech recognition
technology it helps you helps you with
your pronunciation and your accent of
all these different languages Spanish
French Italian German over 14 different
languages not using AI technology they
use the real language experts that make
this real real so this holiday season if
you're looking for a unique gift that
inspires curiosity travel and culture
give the gift of Babel baby Babble
Babble Babble it's addictively fun and
it's easy bite-sized language lessons
just like Edibles that's what it is I
wanted to give you guys the discount and
the site it is babel.com hey babe that's
b-a-b-b-e-l-.com hey babe and right now
you will get 55 off your subscription
when you go to babel.com hey babe that's
babble.com hey babe 55 off your
subscription thank you Babble TT May
pregunto
hello
fresh hello fresh how you doing
how you doing hey low fresh I love
hellofresh tis deceiving tis the season
for saving money Steven so hellofresh
it's here to help make the most of every
moment and they have got for all this
for the holidays we're gonna get they
got make grocery ad grocery shopping 25
less expensive and the food is delish
they have family friendly uh menus they
got all different kinds whether you're
vegetarian meat eater whatever you want
to do and they have festive eats which
makes Meal Time a snap they you choose
from holiday inspired dinner recipes
seasonal add-ons and even a three course
offering you can have a three-course
offering with a three-piece shoot
to make holiday meals extra yummy and
easier than ever so go down Venetia I
can't wait to tell them what the website
is and the discount because I want them
to get discounts all the fans here at
hey babe and I want you to tweet us pics
of your food
so go to hellofresh.com hey babe18 and
use the code hey babe18 for 18 free
meals plus free shipping hellofresh.com
hey babe18 use the code hey babe 18 for
18 free meals you don't even have to be
over 18 or actually you do let's just
say you do hello fresh America's number
one meal kit
[Laughter]
do you know what my favorite Chaz movie
is sing too is he in that no I wish I
was just singing the song from sing too
that is a good one down to earth yeah
Chaz is by the way Chaz is [ __ ]
awesome yeah and and I literally I
literally hope uh that I died before him
but if somehow he dies after me I want
to eat his body in a bolognese sauce
why does that sound good yo Chad
bolognaise sauce dude
I want to I want dude the perfect
meals and then dips
that's where you break your fast for
yeah that's the only time I'll break
myself
dude Jazz I love you babe I want to come
up
uh Running Scared have you ever seen
that movie Oh I thought you've been like
emotionally
because I am man
you're like I am yes
what you meant
remember yesterday on the panel with
Norton when I'm pointing at the pig
about the cereal box and I go and I just
randomly said I was like yo [ __ ] the
Quaker guy Norton goes I did
[Laughter]
when we came with the prize because I'm
gonna go home and sit on this
guitar
[Laughter]
I know
I I think you might have to apologize
maybe do a formal apology to the
audience apologize
[Laughter]
what's up guys I'm Steve Byrne
oh
my God oh man it's one of those things
I'm having so much fun I don't even care
what the repercussions are from that
no what do you guys think about Drake's
new
um necklace I thought that was Brittany
Greiner
[Laughter]
yo make that the clip
that's valid she just got out
you know yeah
um yeah what is it what is it about him
apparently um he got about 40
like 42 rings on uh as a necklace and
apparently that was the amount of times
he thought that he found the one oh [ __ ]
yuck yeah
I mean that's just uh oh 21 Savage times
two equals 42.
yeah him and him both
that's a conspiracy it's actually only
for 21 Savage yeah I could see them
together
the funniest internet stuff since Will
Smith since when Twitter was fun for 15
minutes uh he like all the like 21 21.
so there's a song where Drake keeps
rapping at 21 complimenting how cool he
is but it sounds like Drake is a fan
girl yeah a 21 Savage yeah did they both
hook up with Amber Rose is there
something there no they had an album
together would you why oh no see if you
get turned down by Amber Rose no yeah I
actually did I told you that did you I
swear to God
so no I swear to God she I saw her one
day walking like I don't know who Amber
like you know I know who Amber Rose is
right I think she knows who I am at all
and I was walking past her we were in LA
and she goes wait I know you and I was
like uh you know I didn't know like what
this I was like I was like yeah I'm
taking to taro
no I said I said oh yeah uh I'm Chris
and she goes you do comedy right I said
yeah she was like I dm'd you she goes
check your DM I was like okay no you
didn't yeah whatever and then I went I
just missed it and it was from her wow
and she was like saw like a old clip of
like Geico she was like whatever she
said like you know hey you cute white
[ __ ] like you know she said hey
cutie something like that she was like
why don't next time you're in L.A or New
York hit me up and then gave me her
number yeah and was like hit me up and I
you know never and then I missed it and
then I wait so she said check your DMs
and then walked away I swear to god dude
and then why wouldn't she just have the
real conversation in that moment because
that's mysterious dude yeah that's so
weird
hey check your DMs this is too
uncomfortable so so so so so I then you
know I saw that DM and I couldn't I saw
that go back to the other one before
that that too I saw because this is a
video of TT Jerry are about to show
it looks like Eminem and booty shorts
um
it looks like Jasmine if she gets to use
my manscapes
she becomes Howie from Backstreet Boys
yeah yeah so I thought it was that's why
I got with her
so
I wanted to give birth to a legend and
name it Lou Pearlman so that was in sync
who cares
um
let me know what sound looks like up
there
um
or is it down there so
no just kidding if there if there is a
hell Loop Pearlman 100 and his favorite
show is Impractical Jokers
foreign
[Laughter]
so what did I say what was I saying
before Amber Rose Amber Rose so Amber
Rose yeah I was trying I forgot that I
knew that that's what I was talking
about I was hoping nobody remember
because I'm trying to spin out of this
because I know Jasmine's listening oh
okay so but hey it was before I met you
yeah this is so or maybe right when I
met you there's a gray area
um no
[Laughter]
before I met you Delilah was three
you're gonna get killed I love it dude
I'm getting killed anyway
[Laughter]
so I swear to God I see this DM from
Amber Rose with her phone number and I
said Chris don't text or be cool and I
took five cases and sent a text I swear
to God I took Five Paces and then hit
her number and text her immediately I'm
in LA right now you just saw me yeah
that's what I wrote why wouldn't you
that's the exact right thing to write
and that text has been left on red no
since some year between 2013 and 2019.
you know what she did she jiu jitsued
you she she felt for a while slighted
that you did not respond to her she got
the opportunity to see you turn the
power on back to her saying oh I dm'd
you walk away and then she left you on
red so now she's got the the upper hand
yeah you're gonna marry her one day
and then then the next day and then the
next week she married 21 Savage because
she thought he was Chris Delia
I thought 21 Savage had my guy Chris
Talia were the same guy you did
Khalifa not 21 Savage not 21. okay oh
yeah they were married that's right she
has like a pretty wild forehead tattoo
yeah right yeah not not necessarily the
placement I would go for but yeah but at
the end of the day love is love
and she's beautiful though she is
beautiful at the end of the day
um how'd she look in real life at the
end of the day I think vanitya is wildly
attracted to Amber Rose because she
looks like Neymar
she really does so yeah yeah yeah Amber
Rose is [ __ ] gorgeous I mean
beautiful yeah like really just a
beautiful uh beautiful person Beautiful
Soul
um that I've texted once and never heard
from again facetimer yeah yeah I'll give
her a FaceTime she's on the list with
Seinfeld who else has left you unread
Seinfeld Amber Rose
um Louie Louie Louie's left me on red
dice dice left me on Red Ice actually
yeah yeah it was a good lineup yeah dice
Louis Seinfeld Amber Rose
um who else left me on didn't the Dog
Whisperer didn't you text him the dog
whispered who Justin silver
[Laughter]
he's Cesar
um Eric Adams right
I guess Eric Adams while he yes he will
he never responded to our DM after we
had him on our on the on my podcast my
other podcast ran for president Andrew
Yang Andrew Yang but we never had Andrew
yang
he's getting back to us
um
um so so and who else who else is uh who
else has left me on red
um
I think that's really those are the
biggies
[Laughter]
Ali Wong okay I left me on red but that
was friendly
um but still I've asked you know to come
on the show and it was you know scene
and well obviously she didn't put the
read receipts up just so you'd know
Davidson right Davidson Sal
hahaha
Sal's left Beyond red
yeah Pete Davidson left me on red
um um so obviously just kidding
um
uh who else is left I've just never met
any famous people no
no I'm talking about in terms of texting
oh yeah yeah you know [ __ ] Brendan
sagalog that's right
yeah but he always responds
he initiates too much yeah dude [ __ ]
bread did sagalo Brendan sagalog
like you know that commercial you know
that commercial when like I got ants in
my house and it's all like ants like you
know like it's all like people's ants
like you know your Auntie it's like
different ants coming in and out of the
rooms like oh that's the ant bit and I
was like one of those ants could be
Brendan's tackle yeah Mary Jean
reggaeton yeah yeah dude Brendan shakalo
baby if you're listening uh
um come on the show have you ever seen
sagalo in a dress it's pretty hot no
I've never seen sagalo in a dress yeah
no oh we filmed the series where he
played a woman's wife yeah he played my
wife and he wore uh what was that
leopard like a leopard robe dress almost
and uh but he he's so convincingly he is
a Long Island woman because he I think
he modeled it after his own mother but
it's it's like it's spot on it's crazy
he nailed it because my mom got mad at
me saying it was a portrait of her
that's funny
yeah saglow is the best Mario okay my
father-in-law who Frank rigaton is
basically modeled after right he came up
to me and I have like you know nine of
his rifles strapped to my back and he's
like hey looks at my American flag pants
and the whole thing and he goes this is
making fun of me huh yeah and I'm like
yeah dude
hello as a woman she does look like like
some of the Staten Island moms that pick
up their kids and my daughter's school
yeah and she's good like he should be
driving a silver Caravan yeah yeah he
looks like he should be hosting a show
so
um
um yeah man so yeah exactly Santa so I'm
gonna take my kids to see Santa
um this week you know right now I'm in
Charlotte and then I got Asheville and
Charleston Friday Saturday I believe all
are sold out so thank you well hey babe
fans coming and then new dates by the
way at christycomedy.com Florida Austin
Vancouver it's all on there
um but um
but I'm going away this weekend but then
I'm going to take I think I'm gonna do
for the first time uh ever and it's just
you know me and Jazz just thought of it
we're gonna do this this thing and try
to make it a tradition where we're gonna
go see take the kids to see Santa on
Christmas Eve the morning of Christmas
Eve we're gonna take them to see Santa
and we're gonna see we're gonna
um we're gonna have want the kids to see
Santa in the morning and then you know
see him come again late at night and you
know just know that he was there but not
see him ever because he left again in
the morning because we want Jasmine to
say that's what your life's gonna be
like with your father yes
laughs
so we wanted to give him a life lesson
life lesson to my daughters on Christmas
you get a glimpse yeah I wanted to give
a lesson to my daughters that all the
white men in your life are gonna come
and go as they please
they'll always bring gifts they'll
always bring gifts because they work at
night
and you'll never see them because I left
to get already in the morning to go get
drunk mother [ __ ]
have you considered the the logistical
nightmare so here's actually what's
happened I couldn't this is actually it
felt very scary doing this but I got to
tell you it's like it's making my life
uh the stress and Christmas go down to
almost zero okay me and Jazz talk to
each other and said if we're gonna get
each other Christmas gifts let it it we
can do it but it's got to either be two
weeks before or two weeks after we don't
want to put the pressure of having to do
this on this day on each other so so I
was like yeah so I just got it
immediately I just [ __ ] ordered
something blindly on Amazon I was like
here it is two weeks before and that
yeah I just yeah and now people are
starting to trying to steal my data on
my credit card uh no no I got her
something nice and sent it but but and
so and then I guess I get my I guess
I'll get at my gift I get that here she
is I guess I'll get my gift two weeks
after Christmas when my check's clear so
um
no she's gonna tell me she's going to
give me my gift two weeks after she's
gonna she's gonna give me something
she's gonna come with me on a road trip
um I think to Houston Dallas or New
Orleans which is up in January
um so she's gonna come but
we what we did was the lesson truth
truly is we said we're not gonna do that
and then we called my family like the
adults in my family and said not we are
not we love you Christmas spirit but
like in order to enjoy the Christmas
spirit even more we're gonna cook
something and bring it to the Christmas
Eve dinner like from ours to yours yeah
but we don't want to go through the
stress of having to get each adult gifts
yeah and we also even furthermore we
wanted to do if we could do a Chris
Kringle right now for to try to teach
our kids because we have a lot of kids
in the family now to not want to get
like to not like Get over done with the
presents instead of every single one
instead of us just saying we're going to
get all the kids gifts because then the
kids get so so many gifts we did a Chris
Kringle amongst the adults what's a Kris
Kringle is like you put your name
put names in a hat
and we took it out and like I got my
aunt's kids so I'm the only one buying
my aunts you know from our immediate
family I just one member gets you your
gift I focus on on your kids and then
you know she'll get my aunt will get her
own children yeah gifts but that's what
it is and it is literally from not
having to feel like you have to show up
with a million presents I know some
people like that but it's not even about
oh being selfish it's like there's no
gift of giving here it's like all I'm
doing is like forcing myself to buy you
something you probably don't really need
as opposed to it's giving to just like
sit in a room and like be with each
other and like celebrate that Jesus was
was born on a flat Earth but he was born
in September
yeah Grant Hancock tells me all I need
to know where Nicole and I were like hey
man we've at this point celebrated 27
Christmases together like we've known
each other
having sex with a woman when you were
19. yeah
what 15. no because I was trying to say
like like you've been with her for 27
years and I'm like you set up another
podcast yeah and she's had her own too
yeah an assistant live yeah no I know
they were broken up we both have HBO
yeah no but I know I know I know from um
I know from knowing Mike for a long time
that he was with Nicole for his wife and
still is for 20 plus years but they had
a two-year split two yeah two to three
year split where uh when in in the early
2000s where Nicole was dating Pete
Davidson
how do you get past that like what what
of what the two-year Gap you just
ignored oh it's more than two years she
she had see we but we always like came
back to each other so we dated
consistently like we dated in fifth
grade we dated in terms of like we
hugged on the playground and then all of
our friends laughed and then we all
played kickball yeah and then sixth
grade in Middle School we like held
hands dated seventh grade did you get
your sweaty hand you got the sweatiest
hands yeah
yeah I pruned her up I never thought
that's how much Nicole and sick trade
first time she already answers like even
though see this guy's hands are sweating
she just took him out of a bucket yeah
it feels like he literally took them out
of a bucket and this is what I'm gonna
sign my life up to good girl yeah I like
it only a woman could make that decision
you know what I mean like Nicole knew
from then I had to like go through my
own mental gymnastics to try to figure
out that I even wanted a wife she's like
she she knew even then she's like she's
she's like Mike is just gay enough yeah
give me an easy life and that's what
Jasmine says too yeah it's one of those
guys we're just gay enough that they
know we're straight we're definitely
straight we have like a good prowess but
we are gay in the gay family
will never like you know hit them we'll
never go into like we're Alpha enough to
like take charge sex actually never go
through it we'll also get paid yeah
we'll get pegged it's like yeah listen I
take all the I pay all the bills in this
house I take care of the kids you don't
got to work babe I got you but I sit
down when I pee
[Laughter]
that's pocket money burning up all your
subscriptions that you forgot about
Love Rocket money you're wasting your
money on subscriptions because half the
time you subscribe to something and then
you forget about it but 80 percent of
people have subscriptions they forgot
about 80 per cent okay that's a b to a B
minus depending on what kind of school
district you're in but rocket money
rocket money first of all they got a
podcast
Rocky rocket money podcast talking uh
points three rocket money rocket money
podcast talking points three there's
this app that's okay so that what that
was was a poor copy and paste shot by
Venetia and but rocket money rocket
money is they still love you babe who
loves you babe rocket money okay I'm
telling you you no longer have to waste
money on subscriptions that you don't
even use rocket money it was not
formally known as true bill okay it was
true bill uh and then that that true
bill and then it became true Father Bill
and then it became rocket money and so
so so
rocket money and right now I want you to
go to rocketmoney.com hey babe because
it can genuinely save you hundreds per
year maybe even thousands depending on
what you're subscribing to you know I
don't know everybody loves feet so
go to rocketmoney.com hey babe that's
rocketmoney.com hey babe Gonna Save You
hundreds per year the app shows all your
subscriptions in one place and cancels
what you don't want for you rocket money
can't even find subscriptions you didn't
know you were paying for dummy you may
even find out you've been double charged
for a subscription hate when that
happens to cancel subscription all you
have to do is press cancel and Rocket
money takes care of the rest that's
right cancel with rocket money
don't cancel the subscription to this
podcast
good
here we go mint mobile Ryan Reynolds
company the sexiest man I've ever seen
genuinely in my life Ryan Reynolds mint
mobile I mean I have it because I love
the service but I would have it just
because I want to be close to I wish
Ryan Reynolds so mint mobile I've been
using it long before the holiday deals
are you kidding me way before the
holidays you know come on yeah
but if you haven't been then the holiday
it's the perfect time to switch now mint
Mobile's best offer of the year is here
for a limited time by any three month
plan and get three months free that's
how good mint mobile is to you they got
um they have significance they pass
significant savings Onto You by going
online only and eliminating the
traditional cost of retail that's what
smart Ryan Reynolds is smart so just
switch to Mint mobile and get premium
wireless service starting at just 15
bucks a month and for a limited time get
any three month mint Mobile plan and get
three more months free by going to
mintmobile.com hey babe that's
mintmobile.com hey babe and you're gonna
get three months free on any three month
plan and you know what that is mint so
yeah so speaking of my dad Elon Musk he
got food
Elon Musk Elon Musk got booed on stage
at a Dave Chappelle Show I saw this I
think it was in San Francisco yeah
that's where he's at now that's where
Twitter is oh Elon I thought elon's not
in Austin I mean he lives in Austin for
sure but Silicon Valley is where Twitter
is so I think that's where he's been at
so I didn't so here's the thing here's
here's you know I granted I don't know I
don't know uh much because I the last
couple weeks I've been filming a TV show
that's going to premiere on a network I
can say but just know it's nice
so so uh so but what I saw here is that
Chappelle did a show I think the chase
Center where the Golden State Warriors
playing San franian Arena yeah of course
you just [ __ ] sell that out like a
day so Elon musk's whose mom body walks
on dude somebody is like his body is
preposterous because it all he's like
fat but it all builds to a chest yeah
it's you know but the chest looks like
fake yeah it's it's it's it's he's got a
weird Bond I know what it is you know to
to bomb on a Jumbotron too
um have you done that no well I I I've
talked I've told the story before when I
2015 you know all these years ago
um and and uh they put me on the
Jumbotron at MSG at a Rangers game and I
literally it was right after Phil
Collins like one or two people in the
entire entire Arena collapsed and my dad
was there and I swear to God he was like
rubbing like my back like because he
knew how painful it was to just take a
fast zero and I posted on my did you
tell the story of us kissing on the
jumbo drum oh my God
I forgot about that
we did do that they immediately went
away because did I Chris and I go hey
and then we just turned our face and as
we like got right as I went from cheek
to lips yeah did they like yeah pulled
the camera yeah yeah we tried to pull it
off so we just kissed for no good reason
no good reason you guys wanted to
but but what was I saying what were we
saying what were we saying what we were
saying um about the kids gifts I do the
so I wanted to just be a helpful thing
where it's like you don't have to feel
like you have to buy for everyone that's
really not what what Christmas is about
and it's more about Kwanzaa anyway it's
a good lesson though because that's my
my favorite part about Christmas has
been the combining of families too yeah
like Nicole's family is Italian they
don't have much musicality or anything
like that but they have great food and
they're warmth and like togetherness is
really great yeah and then my family has
like a totally different way of
expressing themselves through the
holidays which I bet a lot of people
would consider nightmarish yeah because
you know my sisters are on the piano
they're singing it's like you know
everybody's cooking for all that stuff
and the combining of that like Nicole's
family is like it's so nice to have
music in the house like they're like
they couldn't believe it that this came
in so it was just like the joining of
things was just uh it was beneficial
forever it wasn't one blowout fight
no that's like behind closed doors so
that that never happens publicly but you
always find out on like December 27th
that two ants aren't talking anymore
and they'll never talk to each other
again and it's a huge huge but thank you
because listen Christmas is definitely
100 about the kids the ninos but it it
it is it's it's it's the ninos
ninos
babble.com hey babe so changing of your
body
sorry this is the 70s 80s and 90s got
too used to it yeah so
dude so uh probably how Leo felt after
filming Django
you guys think you could act that hard
and say the n-word on screen no I mean
I'd snap right into it I'm sure
no I think I think that would be really
hard to do especially like with with
like viciousness in your voice and like
making eye contact and stuff dude that
that would be like a little you have to
deaden something I'm gonna try to have
I'm gonna try everything in my power to
have season two of my TV show on spice
that I'm gonna try to have I just it
would be an honor I'm gonna try to have
Quentin Tarantino direct an episode just
so I can say it
so so sick if that if like there was
some way and obviously not but if there
was some way you could get a world
renowned movie director to direct one
episode that would actually be James
Cameron directs your [ __ ] battle show
like how sick would that be that would
be unreal and honestly it's in the realm
of possibility foreign
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
pipes so
um so
but I think Christmas is about the
children it's about the kids and and
it's one of those things where it's like
you shouldn't have to be forced to buy a
a a a a present for someone over the age
of 18 unless they have Down syndrome or
something I wouldn't
or up syndrome this is hey babe and and
[Laughter]
um
that sounds good yeah man so um you know
I think uh I think you know I think that
it's about the kids man don't be forced
to buy an adult a gift yeah and take a
lot of pressure off yourself and
intermittent fast those are the lessons
of the day yeah and uh and the girl from
Wednesday is over 18. the lead actors
from Wednesday is 20 years old yeah
which is from another podcast that we
did an hour ago
and a different show but that's right
yeah so um and then I mean let's talk
about Harry and Megan a little bit
before we go here have you watched the
documentary dude it's enraged it's
enraging yeah even my wife who is like
fully on board fully on board has
watched like the whole thing and it's
like these are like two of the most
narcissistic people I've ever seen
talking my entire life because it it's
it's very like we just found out about
racism right it's the worst yeah I think
you guys like gotta hear about this yeah
and it's like guys just because you it's
like Miley when she found weed and then
her whole show was weed everywhere weed
everywhere and it's like you guys just
figured this out so I completely
understand your passion for it but
you're saying this as if it's like brand
new information yeah like what do they
say
um what happened is that they were
um Megan like went on air and she was
like thinking how crazy it is that that
you have to curtsy and then she like
reenacts it right now in front of her
husband and it's kind of like a little
awkward and then now because the husband
is like what are you doing you're
disrespecting the curtsy yeah basically
basically this is
that's the most disgusted by the top of
her head he's ever been it's funny
[Laughter]
it's one way and everybody's like uh
this isn't equal so it's kind of dicey
but no it's definitely not definitely
Madness go back to that tweet for a
second
but also like why don't so I'd be
interested in this if they if they
absolutely spoke about this openly it's
completely Fair it is their experience
but let's get into also the kid
trafficking the the uh the the
colonizing yeah like the genuine evil of
the of the crown right and then we can
like then we can take you seriously but
you're only like they were like pissy
towards Megan because she's black and
it's like yeah and like what else what
else is there Doc is supposed to be
about Megan and um her husband's like
you know in like with them in the
British tabloids and like them exploding
them so that's why they had to leave but
it just becomes something totally
different when they're truly
narcissistic and yeah so and now I think
that I think that they're not allowed
Harry and Megan are not allowed to go to
the um
Buck like they're not allowed in England
anymore right they're not allowed on
like the Royal grounds they were just
there but I think now they're not like
they're not getting invited to weddings
they're not doing it I don't think
Andrew is yeah yeah it's crazy he's
totally yeah he's totally still in the
mix which is nuts uh but yeah they're I
don't think they're allowed at like
official functions but they're
definitely allowed in the country like
they're they're like still part of their
family but they're like we don't want to
publicly be I think there has been an
extra thing since this came out which it
came out recently they're in America or
Canada now Harry and America in I guess
LA right yeah so and and it's like I
wonder like too like in America dude
like are they gonna expand is so good
she came back up do people like them in
America or is it like love hate like a
Kardashians thing or most people just
hate them because people love the
Kardashians I do I think that they like
them but then when they do like Wax [ __ ]
like this it's like ill you you lost us
uh they're like what is that called the
presidential whatever that that
percentage that poll was way higher a
month ago than it is now like I think
people saw this and they're like oh
that's that's who you guys are I bet you
Harry too probably started out like a
really nice guy with his own beliefs and
then got into a relationship with a
toxic woman that slowly changed who he
was as a man he now seems like a good
guy yeah I was gonna say and he still
seems like a good guy even though every
day of his life he's just like we were a
Nazi costume
even though every day of his life he's
just like grips grits and bears it and
he tries to slowly just fight off the
person that this toxic Woman made him
become and I don't know what that's
about well there oh
just another joke babe I'm kidding just
yeah that's what it's comparing her to
Princess Diana so that's kind of weird
really she's like they compare all of
them though they compared Kate Middleton
to that because she was attractive and
everybody had all their like their
attention on her it was just uh I don't
know the whole thing is just so weird
this this hero worship over people like
born into a proven murderous regime is
like insane to me yeah I know I'm I'm on
the opposite end of the High Spectrum
where I'm like tin foil hat like let's
take down the ground man I'm with you I
feel like why does she get more love
than Melania this feels just like I'm a
doc about Melania right she's yeah she's
she's a younger Melania okay because
she's more like uh she's more towards
like popular social causes she's more in
favor of those so Melania doesn't I mean
she's she doesn't even really speak
publicly but she is like more of the uh
I'm the empathizer that's her brand you
know Melania in like Hospital terms
means like when a patient has like
explosive diarrhea
m-e-l
and go to m-e-l-e-n-a
diarrhea
sorry yeah
Melina oh it's it's Melina dark stools
means uh uh blood uh blood in your [ __ ]
but it's but it's a stupid thing I even
brought up because her name is Melania
and this is Melina so you want to see
Sal he's they got a whole tour going
through February Arenas all that stuff
and he's going to be on the podcast soon
but you really want to see Mike cannon
at the grammar that's right Gramercy
Theater New York City February 25th 2023
tickets at mikecanoncomedy.com I
genuinely appreciate anybody from this
pod that comes out and uh I have other
dates all over the country before then
as well yo all these dates
um that you that you got and um and go
see it I will be there at that show
um so um Sal will too which is what date
again February 25th February 2015
comedy.com so if I'm booked at my side
christyconomy.com on February 25th know
that I'm Gonna Cancel that show last
minute that's right
um and I won't redeem your tickets so
No I um uh it was a pleasure to have you
Mike Sal I'm obviously just kidding
around he's not dead that we know of but
he but but he's he's coming back next
week whether I bring him out in a body
bag or not and no no salary back I know
you guys have been worrying or wondering
like I've said he's just working on the
practical jokers so busy and they're so
busy then he's on tour and he's got a
whole bunch of great things coming uh to
you from Sal's World
um but he will be back on on hey babe
it's just you know you got to give the
guy a break so uh and so and and when he
does get a break that's when we'll be
recording the episodes yeah yeah the one
minute one day as a break I'm gonna say
no you can't talk to your family you got
to do the hey babe with me
um so so so
um or else I'll [ __ ] kill myself live
on the hay Bay platform and just leave a
note saying I did this because of Sal
vulcano's toxic masculinity
you were just like looking down you're
like or else I'll kill myself no I'm
kidding I I wouldn't do it Jasmine would
do that for me
um no no I'm kidding man if I'm gonna
die man it's gonna I'll dot if I'm gonna
die it's gonna be from happiness I
promise you that just like I hope you
guys are dead from happiness from this
show we love you happy holidays uh I
don't think we'll see you again for the
new year but we should tell them what
we're about to do on your patreon
what is that we're gonna smoke the
freeze pipe we're gonna smoke you guys
are somehow gonna get higher right we're
going to get higher at patreon.com
Christy comedy smoke a freeze pipe put
that in your pipe and smoke it so so so
but but but um but I wanted to tell you
also that Sal will be back and um and uh
uh
uh um
what I was gonna say I was gonna say
something oh a big there's parts of this
episode that have been edited out
because we were being too high and too
crazy and all that would be a
patreon.com Christy comedy a couple of
them are going to squeeze in but a lot
of that probably can't say or maybe we
just leave it in pimp it's your call and
we'll see what happens
it's whatever it is man there's just
gonna be blocks of us
screaming cut to us crying
imagine the lawyers from your other show
on this show oh my gosh oh my God oh my
God I'm excited to read the ads this has
been hey babe
hahaha
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey babe